even after working for 18 years I
believe you are never too old to learn
new skills and acquire knowledge to
excel further and keep up the growth
that's why I decided to upskill myself
to hone my skills to improve my
performance in my current organization
the course not only helped me to acquire
skills and get certified but also gave
me a decent salary hike hey I am Aditya
Canaria I live in Pune with my family
I am currently working as a quality
manager at the source system Global
Services I recently got certified in the
postgraduate program in lean Six Sigma
in collaboration with UMass armrest from
Simply learn I'm a curious learner and
continuous Improvement is my motto this
isn't the first time I choose simply
learn to upskill myself
I even took the project management
course earlier which motivated me to go
for another one I am working in the
quality management domain for 18 years
now when I was assigned position of
quality manager I decided to take up the
course in Lindsay Sigma I wanted to make
sure that I am fully updated with all
the recent case studies to master myself
in the field of quality management the
course boosted my knowledge of case
studies from Harvard Business publishing
and Capstone project from kpms in India
that provide real world lead and Six
Sigma exposure one of the best
attraction of simple and course is a
well-structured course content that
consists of all the industry 11 models
and projects the concepts were easier to
learn thanks to the pedagogy of the
faculty everything they taught was
practical and experience driven even the
support team made the learning smoother
because of their instant response and
with problem solving the certification
has already made me stand out from the
crowd and has brought me closer to my
goal of excelling in the field of
quality management in my leisure time I
spent my time cooking delicious food and
trying my hands at new recipes I also
love photography and enjoy clicking
pictures with my DSL learning gives me
thriving for perfection
keeps me growing professionally because
growth is the only constant that leads
to success
[Music]